[Music]
in santiago de chile from school primer
leaf understand game plays today since it
started 6 in m and just this first month
of classes we have noticed two
real changes in the girls who just arrived
this year they can cry in peace
without anyone judging and  you can laugh at
things you didn't do before
[Music]
my name is evelyn silva and I am the
director of the amaranta school the
transit of selena changed my life
completely i quit my job and
decided to dedicate myself to activism
full time and on the path of  that
dedication to activism I found the
school I did not realize that the
boys and girls dropped out of the
school system stressed out in trouble they suffered
bullying they suffered invisibility a lot of
invisibility and I opened the school in
April 2018 we left with
6 children and today we have 38
andrés
bien
how
mayné espinoza come out in english
teacher agape
there is a website and that they will
experience the casting of the soft
woman yes  they have opening this nest
[Music]
with extensive moral type projectors
numbers dedicate fun names in
güines lose we don't take the league
of names and schools wertheimer and
discriminate for trips or the ethics of
salteras obviously from chopin is leaving der
kamp your wife from  eifel stay in the
neighborhood phases haiti bernard exclude the
animal
[Music]
the other schools personally what
happened to me is that in the morning my
stomach started to hurt a lot because it made me
very nervous not on the contrary
like if it makes me want to come  I feel
that being with other people is trans of
different ages I think it helps you a lot with
the issue that sheen has some kind of
problem in quotes like the one that
others understand you and in this step the
younger children kind of teach you a
lot of new things
I think  that this is very important because
people think that only
adults teach and not children as well
I would like the amaranta school to
fulfill two roles  s in the future one that
we could spread this knowledge to
other schools and the other is that the
boys and girls who are here feel
the freedom to be themselves either
trans or us
ah
[Music]